Israel is the only country in the world
never allowed to win a
war that's why by the way you have the
situation in the Gaza you have all the
international idiots telling the
Israelis they have to withdraw and then
what happens you give the Palestinians a
statet and they they give you Hamas and
War uh anyone who thinks the West Bank
is going to be a Palestinian state is
now living with a fairies and it's not
because of the Israelis it's because the
Palestinian Authority hasn't wished to
create a St for decades it never did
it's only ever been interested in
creating a state from The River To The
Sea as they always say it's never been
interested in a two-state solution
Palestinian Authority under two leaders
now has repeatedly turned down every
Israeli offer uh of of peace they
offered 99% of what they wanted just 15
years ago they turned it down again as
AAS Arafat did at Oslo they don't want a
two-state solution they want a one-state
solution and that's a Jewish cleared
Palestinian state